[Music]
the gene editing revolution has arrived
promising cures for terminal disease
in the past five years you know we've
made more progress than in the previous
50.
a new approach is to fighting climate
change we have the opportunity to
fundamentally change our relationship
with nature
but new genetic technologies bring with
them new ethical and practical risks
some of it could be terrifyingly
threatening like bio warfare what is our
responsibility as scientists and doctors
it's really starting to bring out ideas
around who belongs and who doesn't
belong
so how should the promise of genetic
technologies be balanced against the
potential dangers
and who decides what risks are worth
taking
um
[Music]
this is professor james dale
a man on a mission
to save the world's most popular banana
from extinction
i reckon these williams are the ones
that were most spectacular weren't they
cool
that's incredible
there are thousands of types of banana
in the world
but all the fruit being grown and
processed here and almost every banana
exported around the world is one single
variety
the cavendish
it yields very well it's got quite a
tough skin so it travels well but also
it it's got a really acceptable taste
and texture
the problem is the cavendish is under
threat
a disease known as tropical race 4 or
tr4 has spread across the world killing
cavendish bananas
tr4 one of the deadliest plant diseases
out there they call it the cancer of the
bananas
to start you start to get that sort of
motley coloration there it gets worse
and now it's reached james's plantation
and what we're looking for is the brown
which is what we call necrosis
and then you see bingo that was the one
that had the yellow leaves just
incredible necrosis
there is no cure for this disease
it's fear that in time it could wipe out
the cavendish completely
or stop it being such an economically
valuable crop
it is a really serious problem there's
no obvious replacement for cavendish
bananas for the export market
but james has a solution
he has spent 10 years engineering a
genetically modified banana which can
withstand tr4
there's a big problem though
because james's bananas are genetically
modified lots of consumers won't go
anywhere near them
it is unbelievably frustrating gm still
has a lot of perceived negativity in the
world europe for instance is one of
those areas that they import huge
amounts of bananas but getting a gm crop
through the regulatory process in europe
is virtually impossible
he believes this public resistance could
block the development of beneficial new
crops
i think it's a real problem we're moving
into a period of real flux a real
unknown period with climate change and
we're going to need to develop crops
that have very high tolerance to drought
i'm not sure that we have all of the
tools at our fingertips without the use
of gm and gene editing so i think there
is a real ethical dilemma in the world
now of rejecting technologies that may
become incredibly important over the
next decade or two
some believe gm technology can be used
to do lots of good
so
is it right to put barriers in the way
because others oppose the technology on
principle
[Music]
in an eu-wide poll
70 said they felt gm foods were
unnatural but that's a very vague term
the things that people actually grow in
gardens and in fields
are really not particularly natural many
of them have genomes that have been
extensively
changed over the course of human history
if you look at
what a modern era of maze looks like
compared to its ancestral form you'll
see something very different
yet there is still a fear that these
technologies could go astray
and expose people to risks they have not
agreed to
[Music]
[Applause]
this is isla morada a tropical paradise
that's on the front line of the debate
about genetic engineering
here genetically modified mosquitoes are
being released in the united states for
the first time
is part of an experiment to try to
reduce the spread of zika and dengue
fever
but some of the locals have been very
vocal about their opposition to this
kind of intervention into the natural
world
our economy here is tourist-based and a
lot of tourists are lay people and if
they come down here and they hear that
we're turning loose some kind of weird
critter i think that there could be some
impact on the economy
[Music]
as a result the mosquitoes have to be
released in top secret locations away
from protesters and vandals
[Music]
we just add regular tap water the eggs
hatch in about 24 hours
there's already food in there
and you can see these little holes on
both sides that's where the adult males
are going to come out of
[Applause]
the authorities hope this will solve the
problem posed by aedes aegypti
a mosquito which can carry zika and
dengue and in some places has become
resistant to pesticides
baby's aegypti control is very expensive
what we find is that it takes up over 10
percent of our entire budget to control
a very small population of our
mosquitoes
up till now mosquito control here has
involved going door-to-door clearing
standing water
british company oxitec might put an end
to that
with a genetic approach that has female
mosquitoes in its sights
only the females bite and carry disease
and oxitec is getting to them through
the males
it altered the genes of some male
mosquitoes so that when they mate with
females only their male offspring would
survive
meaning the number of females should
crash within a few generations
it's essentially birth control for
mosquitoes it's a biological solution
it's targeted against one species and it
has no effect against bees butterflies
or other pollinators
the project is a field trial which has
been approved by america's environmental
protection agency the epa
but the way the technology is regulated
has provoked concerns
the protocols for evaluating genetically
modified organisms are way short on a
lot of things
natalie kofler is a harvard-based
bioethicist who has attended many of the
town hall debates about this program
what i'm really concerned about is
really how it's being decided upon and
developed not the technology itself
she says the regulation of this
technology isn't transparent enough and
doesn't require proper engagement with
affected communities
it's just blowing our regulatory systems
apart
one of the biggest challenges
is the real need for community consent
when we're talking about releasing and
genetically modified organisms into
people's literal like backyards we don't
have space that empowers community
members in this process or gives them
any real sort of agency that to me is a
really really big concern
failing to engage communities properly
not only risks intervening in their
lives without consent
it also raises another ethical concern
the risk of turning people against the
technology meaning that they and others
miss out on beneficial interventions
by not engaging communities we're
setting up gmo storm 3.0 where you know
we already have so much distrust in that
space this could just you know create
entirely new concerns
the emergence of new types of gene
editing is raising the stakes in this
debate
gene editing is getting cheaper and
easier making the technology more widely
available
one of the biggest recent advances has
been the development of a technique
known as crispr
which in 2020 won a nobel prize for its
inventors emanuel charpontier and
jennifer doudna
human beings now have the ability to
rewrite the code of life
crispr makes precise edits in dna by
using a special protein which can be
programmed with a molecule called rna
so that when it finds a specific gene
sequence it makes a cut at that precise
point in the dna
the techniques combination of precision
and ease of use opens up the prospects
of tackling genetic diseases more
effectively than ever before you cranked
her up
jumped into the front seat and off you
went with a family
i think of crispr as being kind of like
the model t ford
there were cars before the model t
but they were really expensive and they
broke down all the time once the model t
came out everybody could have a car and
so with crispr it's just
faster cheaper easier better mighty
smooth riding
[Music]
this ability to edit specific genes
could change medicine dramatically and
soon
there are 200 million people on our
planet are fellow human beings who
suffer from genetic diseases that are
crisperable in principle
one of the most recent advances is the
ability to treat sickle cell disease
a blood disorder which is caused by a
mutation in a single gene
this new technology is already here and
already changing lives
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
josh lehrer runs graphite bio
a company researching crispr-based cures
for the disease
he was inspired by his time as a junior
doctor when sickle cell treatment was
basic
i was in medical school
taking care of of of my first patient
with sickle cell disease and we had
really nothing to offer
besides morphine and blood transfusions
which were essentially the same ways
that this disease was treated in the
1950s nothing had really changed what
we're hoping to find here is ways to
actually kind of keep improving the
efficiency
josh's company is working on what he
calls next generation gene editing
treatments if we had an approach that
could go beyond cutting and essentially
find and replace correct that defect and
restore the normal hemoglobin protein
that should be a definitive cure
while most would be in favor of using
gene editing to cure a disease-like
sickle cell
it gets more complicated when the
technology is used to fix diseases and
conditions which may be less
debilitating i think what bothers people
a lot about gene editing isn't the idea
of editing away terrible diseases
it's the idea of editing traits that
aren't diseases at all like eye color or
skin color i think these are going to
raise some really difficult questions
[Music]
at this lab in moscow
scientists are engaged in one of the
most controversial applications of
crispr
they're using gene editing to try to
eliminate hereditary deafness
uh
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
who leads the research says he has three
deaf couples lined up for treatment
and that
[Music]
[Music]
while denise does not yet have approval
from the russian regulators to implant
edited embryos into patients
he hopes it will only be a matter of
time
[Music]
and for many deaf people and beyond this
is a deeply troubling prospect
teresa blankmeyer burke is a bioethicist
who teaches at gallaudet university a
college for the deaf so guess what deaf
people are not the first people to get
this information whenever
we have
technology
that can change the world
we need to be very thoughtful
about how we use it
she worries using crispr to cure
deafness could damage efforts to improve
understanding and integration of deaf
people
i think
we're experiencing
a deaf renaissance
that this kind of experience
this kind of community
needs to continue but we can't continue
if we have the threat of dissolving us
as a people
some fear editing genes related to
conditions like deafness could pave the
way towards building so-called designer
humans
the gene editing conversation is
important because it's really starting
to bring out ideas around who belongs
and who doesn't belong and i think those
are really important social questions
that we need to reckon with
many rich countries already offer
screening to pregnant women for
disorders like down syndrome
and some fear the elimination of
conditions like this would simply be a
logical next step and set a worrying
precedent
it's a evolution of you know
pre-implantation genomics we have
selective abortion we're already
choosing potential for genetic disorders
etc it's just one next step then just
maybe being able to tailor those genomes
for certain traits
editing embryos is especially
controversial because it can cause
genetic changes to be passed down
through the generations via what is
known as germline editing
so germline editing affects potentially
at least your children grandchildren
great grandchildren and potentially
until the end of the species
the doctor who sparked global outrage by
claiming to produce the world's first
genetically modified baby
germline editing has already caused an
international outcry
in 2018 a chinese scientist announced he
had edited embryos using crispr to make
them immune to the hiv virus
two beautiful little chinese girls named
lulu and lana came crying into the world
as healthy as any other babies a few
weeks ago
he said that twin girls have been born
as a result who could now pass this
immunity down to their children as a
father of two girls
i can't think of a gift more beautiful
and wholesome for the society than
giving another couple a chance to start
a loving family
but the scientific community didn't
agree
his experiment was seen as premature and
dangerous
so i think we still need to understand
the motivation for the study
and what the process was for informed
consent
the risks to these babies were enormous
and the potential benefits were really
quite small
in a way that made it i think criminally
reckless
per john quay was imprisoned by the
chinese authorities
and since then there have been calls for
a global moratorium on germline editing
this could put the brakes on denise's
research in russia and he says he's keen
to see more debate about editing embryos
regularly
[Music]
[Music]
while gene editing of human embryos is
tightly regulated
the same can't be said about other areas
in some countries fruit and veg in which
specific genes have been precisely
edited aren't subject to the same
regulation as old genetically modified
produce
which typically contain genes
transplanted in from some other species
and while the eu still bans gene-edited
food crisper produce can be bought in
japan and america
some believe this comparatively
permissive regulation around gene-edited
plants should give pause for thought
i don't know any country that i think
has a good regulatory structure for this
it's a lot easier to do wild experiments
with non-humans and with humans some of
those will turn out to be
good useful some of them could be turned
out to be terrible some of them will
turn out to be frivolous but if we don't
pay attention to them
we're likely to get lots of bad results
we need a better regulatory scheme
but advocates of the revolution in
gene-edited foods see numerous
possibilities for improving production
this is the first start of our screening
process for our gene edited bananas
back in australia james is using crispr
to develop another disease-resistant
cavendish banana so we're setting up
here
the challenge protocol
these gene-edited bananas will contain
no foreign dna and so won't be subject
to the same strict regulation as his gm
variety
he hopes they could be the answer to the
looming banana crisis
we can take them out to field trial
without getting any of those sorts of
permissions and can take them all the
way through to commercialisation which
is fabulous
from tomatoes which might lower blood
pressure to mushrooms that don't go
brown
gene edited foods promise opportunities
for addressing the challenges facing
global agriculture
the age of crispr completely changes the
way we think about agriculture
perhaps the greatest benefit of crispr
could be in tackling the planet's
biggest challenge
climate change
[Music]
it is in making safe nutritious more
climate change tolerant crops for the
world is where we really see us the
future of the biggest impact that crispr
can make
and it's not just crops whose genes are
being edited to help curb global warming
it's animals too
[Music]
this is pleistocene park
site of an audacious plan to bring back
animals that lived here tens of
thousands of years ago
and in doing so
counter climate change
one of the more jaw-dropping
is the woolly mammoth
[Music]
a team of american scientists are
working to recreate the prehistoric
beasts by applying gene editing to
elephants
we've been trying to
reduce the endangerment of the elephants
by reviving some ancient dna variations
found in mammoths
[Music]
scientist george church hopes to use
mammoth dna to create an elephant
capable of surviving cold temperatures
to repopulate siberia with these new
animals
we're not creating a new species or a
hybrid species so much as a rescuing
asian elephant
he hopes these animals could one day
help control climate change
by trampling the snow and exposing the
permafrost to freezing air which should
stop it melting and releasing greenhouse
gases
if they're focused on the parts of the
arctic that are richest in carbon and
most at risk then it could have an
impact comparable to a gigaton of carbon
dioxide for a year
it's a bold claim
and even if it worked as he suggests its
effect on the overall climate would be
pretty small
many worry that the headline-grabbing
nature of projects like this are
diverting attention away from more
pressing conservation issues
if it starts making people think of
extinction as less of a problem then i
think that there could be severe worries
that said in some ways the extinction
and also
the associated thing of being able to as
it will reinflate gene pools when things
are close to extinct i think that's very
encouraging the idea of being able to
bring back diversity that would
otherwise be lost
gene editing has the potential to
transform life on earth and as
scientists and society weigh the
potential rewards against the risks
there is a need to tease out what is
simply a fear of the new
and what is a genuine ethical issue
whenever you're talking about ethics and
science there is an innate tendency to
see the science running too fast and
ethics trying to pull it back i do think
there's also a need to look at what are
the ethical things you would like to see
happen in the world and how might
science bring those about
hello i'm tom standage deputy editor at
the economist if you'd like to learn
more about this topic click on the link
opposite and if you'd like to watch more
of our now and next series click on the
other link thanks for watching and don't
forget to subscribe
you